cet épisode sur le lien entre le double
épisode Japon et l'épisode Star Wars
parce que oui une chronologie
un colis pour vous
merci
[Musique]
tu penses que les gens ont compris que
c'était une japonais je pense que oui
Sébastien je pense que oui
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des jeux japonais une culotte
extraterrestre du grand empire chinois
il souhaite se venger de l'humiliation
infligé par grenier dans la vidéo takes
mais le chien t'avait mangé il en faut
plus que ça pour me tuer
idiot je suis parti m'entraîner très
loin pour devenir plus fort j'ai vécu
des aventures palpitantes et fait des
rencontres formidables et j'ai appris à
révéler mon vrai pouvoir et maintenant
tu vas jouer à tous ces jeux bah non oh
que si connard
je ne contrôle plus mon corps
c'est comme si quelqu'un m'obligeait à
jouer alors que pourtant je peux
continuer à parler pour décrire mes
actions tu ne peux plus rien et tu vas
jouer à ce jeu jusqu'à la mort
euh bon un anneau star Kaidou je
sortirai en 97 sur famille comme on y
joue le rôle de de connards qui viennent
à Tokyo pour réussir à sortir un album
de merdes quoi vous pensez pas que
j'allais faire ça avec le sourire en
plus non le jeu est un platformer
classique à l'exception que vous ne
contrôlez pas un mais deux personnages
en même temps parce que un personnage
c'est pas assez relou donc on s'est dit
qu'on allait mettre deuxième doigt pour
voir si ça rentre bref niveau contrôle
si on appuie sur haut les personnages
s'éloignent de l'autre sur bah il se
rapproche alors on peut sauter tirer des
notes de musique et il va évidemment
falloir réussir à avancer dans cette
espèce de ghetto où tout le monde essaye
de te buter les motards les femmes les
paparazzis les
[Musique]
je suis content d'avoir esquiver ça là
et même Dieu déteste la J-Pop et te
balance constamment des ordures à la
gueule le pet évidemment la plus grosse
difficulté de ce merdier ça va être de
contrôler les deux personnages dans un
jeu rempli de plateformes faites pour un
seul personnage après regardez donc le
jeu il est mignon les personnages sont
souriants il fait beau et pourtant si
c'est moi qui avait développé le jeu
j'aurais rajouté une petite ligne sur le
livret du genre tu vas roter du sang tu
l'es ce jeu est dur à se crever les yeux
bah oui vas-y tiens fais-moi
réapparaître directement au-dessus du
trou là face de cul donc dans chaque
niveau vous allez devoir récupérer
plusieurs disques d'or ainsi qu'un ITEP
spécial selon le niveau que vous allez
devoir droper sur les ennemis pour ça et
bien il faut par exemple prendre cette
femme et l'entourer de chaque côté avant
de se resserrer violemment sur elle ce
qui est complètement une agression
[Musique]
d'ailleurs les fans ont leur pisse au
cul apprenez donc à les mépriser
si par hasard vous réussissez à avoir la
patience de collecter l'item et laissez
vous devez donc aller jusqu'à la maison
de disque qui est évidemment au passage
un [ __ ] de labyrinthe et dans laquelle
pour plus de feux aussi on est obligé
d'attendre poliment que le scrolling de
la caméra va il vienne descendre parce
que sinon on meurt j'ai pas non plus
parler de l'item indispensable là pour
finir le niveau qui disparaît dès que tu
te fais toucher par un ennemi ce qui est
super agréable quand l'ennemi en
question c'est une vieille poule de
merde je t'ai par Dieu à travers
l'interface du jeu ou du c'est quoi ce
décor pourquoi c'est tout vert et vous
faites des plateformes aussi petites
bande de sac à merde vous savez qu'on
est deux non mais allez vas-y mange mes
nouilles [ __ ]
oh je déteste les jeux de plateforme
j'en peux plus non monsieur grenier
rappelez-vous souvenez-vous de
Castlevania de la douce mélodie de Mario
des grandes pleines vertes de Grigny
zone de Sonic vous rappelez des grandes
plaines vertes de greening zone de Sonic
monsieur grenier oh Seb il n'y a rien
entre moi et les jeux pourris je les
vois de mes yeux éveillés cela dit ça
serait dommage de pas insister on dit
qu'après les épreuves les plus dures se
cachent les vrais récompenses alors
voyons un peu la fin de ce jeu
montrez-moi montrez-moi la vraie
récompense bon montrez-nous les gays
vous allez être célèbre
très bien et maintenant prends le je
suivant
quoi on dirait qu'il a réussi à
matérialiser son esprit combatif sous la
forme d'une licorne avec un pagne ça ne
veut rien dire je suis la réincarnation
du yamathano Orchies et je t'ai retrouvé
Suzano en effet
[Musique]
le texte qui a été tué par susanu un
chasseur protégeant sa fille serait
incarne tous les 10 000 ans pour
chercher sa vengeance Pépito serait donc
la réincarnation du Yamata neurochi et
grenier celle de Susano mais je ne suis
pas Susanne subit la puissance de
Starlight unicorne
je le fais mais vraiment parce que le
jeu est déjà dans la console bon
Transformers ce qu'on va une au naso
sorti sur Famicom en 86 le jeu est un
side scroller en deux
[Musique]
ok le jeu étonnant mais [ __ ] le jeu
est une gaufre à la mer beaucoup trop
dur pour un être humain [ __ ] bon vous
contrôlez donc ultra Magnus parce que
c'est évidemment le premier personnage
que les gens veulent jouer dans un jeu
Transformers faisons un jeu Dragon Ball
Z où j'aurais uniquement réagi Robert ça
sera génial donc le but c'est d'avancer
jusqu'à la fin des niveaux simplement
vous l'avez vu
c'est ce genre de jeu seulement deux
vies pas de continue des ennemis tous
les 3 mètres et vous êtes littéralement
moins fort que absolument tous les
ennemis que vous rencontrez même les
ennemis de merde du niveau 1 prennent
deux coups pour mourir alors que vous
non c'est un coup et vous êtes mort mais
c'est bien c'est réaliste tiens j'aurais
aimé que le film soit pareil aussi
ah oui et vraiment super idée de [ __ ]
des projectiles blancs sur une montagne
blanche regardez c'est impeccable je
vois rien bref vous avez deux boutons
sauter et tirer impossible de se baisser
ce qui entre nous est un peu ballot
surtout quand tu es projectiles passent
pas trop haut pour toucher les ennemis
au sol et [ __ ] mais arrêtez de me
flasher la gueule comme ça en fait c'est
quoi ça sert un écran titre ou c'est un
test pour détecter l'épilepsie alors bon
vous pourriez appuyer sur bas pour vous
transformer en camion pour atteindre les
cibles trop basses mais le
transformation est prend un siècle
[ __ ] bon après cela dit la
transformation elle est quand même utile
au moins dans le niveau 1 parce que les
avions ennemis ne peuvent du coup plus
vous toucher dommage que ça s'arrête
tout seul au bout de quelques secondes
allez vas-y fonce 1 2 mais non mais ta
soeur et depuis quand les Autobots là
ils peuvent plus garder leur forme
véhicule indéfiniment
[Musique]
enfin bon le niveau 1 c'est fini c'est
parti pour le niveau 2 et du coup
j'espère que ça sera moins la galère
[Musique]
on entend donc le niveau 2 avec des
nouveaux ennemis variés comme des gambas
ou des moules
savions récents
et le premier gros changement la
transformation en véhicule ne sert plus
à rien puisque tous les niveaux se
passent dans l'espace en mode jeu de
plateforme et que c'est ballot mais les
camions ça saute pas chauffer
reste dans le trou comme
en gros le jeu s'appelle Transformers
mais tu te transformes jamais ah ça
voulait dire ça et de nouveaux problèmes
à partir du niveau 2 et jusqu'à la fin
du jeu les ennemis contrairement à toi
passe tranquillement à travers les murs
et du coup en profite pour se cacher à
travers les textures je croisements
et c'est quoi ce truc de merde là un
ballon de plage des scepticots vous
savez beaucoup de jeux tirés de licence
de cette époque était pas terrible mais
on s'en foutait parce qu'on était juste
content de jouer avec des personnages
connaît mais là il y a même pas ce
plaisir ce jeu c'est un manche de frein
à main collé dans le cul des fans de
Transformers oui c'est je Transformers
alors j'adapte mes blagues sur le thème
de la mécanique je veux dire les décors
sont tellement recyclés qu'il faudrait
coller une étiquette bio sur la jaquette
du jeu et le seul truc qui te rappelle
que tu joues à un jeu Transformers c'est
quand les def viennent te chier un vieux
logo dans l'assiette hé hé regardez ce
truc là c'est un logo decepticots donc
ça va on est bien dans un jeu
Transformers non hé hé je suis mauvaise
langue il y a quand même des sprints de
robots sont nominés pour la meilleure
animation de sprite de la famille comme
et du meilleur décor de fond
[Musique]
Transformers les couilles d'un laser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
a jamais ici passons je suis vivant
plutôt crevé Starlight
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un jeu basé sur la légende du Roi Singe
cette légende chinoise qui a notamment
donné Dragon Ball ce jeu est une légende
il fait partie de la Triforce des jeux
de mer de japonais avec stargazord et
takesh challenge le jeu commence donc
par
[Musique]
j'ai perdu la manette tant pis tiens ça
quoi et comment tu fais pour fabriquer
des trucs aussi vite je suis chinois
je veux dire que j'ai une technologie
galactique qui permet de dupliquer les
temps comme vous le voyez on commence
par un écran de carte du monde ou
visiblement les développeurs se sont dit
Hey ça serait sympa si ton personnage
avait la vitesse d'un caillou
c'est quoi ce jeu c'est aussi fun que de
violer le cheval blanc
on dirige une petite équipe composée du
Roi Singe et du prêtre sur son cheval
alors le jeu a un cycle jour nuit ce qui
est plutôt pas mal pour l'époque quand
même et on dispose de la barre de vie de
chaque membre de l'équipe ainsi que
d'une barre d'eau et de nourriture qui
diminue avec le temps alors le jeu c'est
quoi finalement est bien on est sans but
sur la carte à la recherche du fun et
d'éventuellement une [ __ ] de sortie et
parce qu'au Japon on sait comment
s'amuser
c'est marrant parce qu'il peut mourir et
bien est sorti que vous cherchez sur
cette carte est
difficile
de l'avoir sans marcher dessus par
hasard et c'est pas comme cet autre jeu
qu'on avait déjà testé ou le mec te
donnait à peu près une direction là non
ni indication ni boussole rien et la
carte elle est [ __ ] de gigantesque que
j'ai trouvé sur le net un écran dans ce
jeu tel que vous le voyez là ça
correspond à cette taille
et c'est choc [ __ ] de carré de cet
écran multiplié par le nombre de carrés
de la carte entière que vous allez
devoir fouiller
à cette vitesse
vous êtes astronomiquement con c'est un
niveau divin vous êtes Dieu vous êtes
des dieux nous l'avons trouvé le 0
absolu une absence totale d'un temple de
feutre le jeu pourri des dieux je veux
savoir qui a créé ça et comment un jour
je me promenais dans les bois
et puis je me suis perdu j'ai mis une
journée à retrouver mon chemin et c'est
là où j'ai eu l'idée de faire Legend of
Zelda un jour je me promenais chez moi
et j'ai perdu mes clés j'ai mis trois
jours à les retrouver c'était super
chiant et j'ai eu une idée de faire
super Monkeys surtout que attention
l'emplacement des sorties n'a aucun sens
je veux dire tenez je passe dans une
forêt il y a un léger labyrinthe avec au
bout un renfoncement dans la forêt ce
sera un bon endroit pour [ __ ] une
sortie cachée mais non ils l'auront
foutu en plein milieu d'un champ bref
j'ai pas encore parlé des combats parce
que parfois aléatoirement un combat va
se déclencher et à ce moment-là plus
rien notre sens vous contrôlez dans les
combats les membres de votre groupe dans
l'ordre de ceux qui sont encore en vie
dans cette espèce de boukake de sprite
de merde là
c'est quoi un bouquet en premier son
Goku qui peut taper avec son bâton qui a
juste délai de 2 secondes environ ce qui
fait que si j'appuie à cet endroit là le
coup partira quand l'ennemi il sera là
nickel mais bon à la limite on s'en
prend là vu que les ennemis n'ont plus
de Xbox tu tapes à droite ça touche un
mec à gauche tu tapes et ça touche quand
même et de toute façon est-ce que tu
veux vraiment viser enfin je veux dire
les ennemis se torchent le cul avec de
la logique et des fois les combats vont
s'arrêter au pif avant que tu aies fini
de tuer tous les ennemis en fait c'est
bah il y a plein de bugs mais comme tu
as des plus gros bugs qui viennent
écraser les petits bugs bah du coup ça
marche en fait un docteur j'ai mal à la
tête
ah vous êtes cons vous étiez dans le
bras vous avez toujours mal à la tête
non
[Musique]
alors son Goku qui est le premier
personnage que vous jouez évidemment
peut mourir ainsi il meurt à ce
moment-là vous allez donc jouer le
suivant c'est à dire le prêtre ou le
cheval alors oui alors ce dragon là
c'est le cheval bon alors avec un peu de
recherche invisiblement les développeurs
ont négligé de mettre un sprite de
cheval dans le jeu du coup le cheval
prend en général la forme d'un des
ennemis au pif mais souvent il prend
l'apparence du dragon c'est pas un bug
j'ai oublié merde ça va bon bref alors
je vais pas aller jusqu'au bout du jeu
parce que bah merde je veux dire vous le
finiriez vous le job à place et j'ai
beau avoir essayé de crever de feu ou de
me suicider mais le jeu est tellement
branlé qui il veut même pas me laisser
mourir
laisse-moi mourir [ __ ] ce jeu mais
c'est le godemichet de Satan mais [ __ ]
mais les ennemis se suicident sur moi et
ma vie remonte en plus alors ce jeu est
resté assez inconnu du grand public a
notamment en Occident parce qu'il est
pas aussi populaire que takeshi's Castle
d'ailleurs c'est amusant un des
développeurs a mis un message caché dans
l'écran titre du jeu et pour vous nous
l'avons fait traduire et maintenant un
message de développeur
je m'appelle kaouh nakaima j'ai 26 ans
et je suis né en 1960 à Toyo camacity
dans la préfecture d'haishi je veux
lécher des chattes je veux une femme
perverse j'aime les vagins et les
clitoris
[Musique]
c'était un message
des vas-y souffre tu vas
mais tu n'es pas Suzano
je ne peux plus bouger c'est impossible
c'est comme si
tu as cru que j'étais la réincarnation
de susanu alors qu'en réalité j'étais de
plus tous les jeux que tu m'as obligé à
faire était presque impossible et il
fallait des réflexes surhumains c'est
pour ça que j'ai développé la capacité
d'arrêter le temps ça n'a aucun sens
mais bizarrement j'ai quand même compris
c'est fini pour toi la blague
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Sa Majesté granolax mettez-le dans la
cuve de suite il faut qu'il survivre
les humains nous le verrons tirez les
torpilles vers giaganinx
[Musique]